John you have been a wiggle since 2021
and of course right now your game your
face is everywhere to say the least did
you ever think that the internet would
be going this wild after you as a wiggle
this wild now I didn't think I'd get
that type of response you know I'm just
making fun quirky content that you know
I enjoy and and you know the people
around me enjoy and just you know
keeping it keeping it Wiggly keeping it
myself and
um I never try to read the comments I'll
get to turn to depth about what people
think about it but you couldn't avoid
this one I was getting messages from
friends and family I was getting
articles sent to me left right and
Center so it's um it's all been positive
and it's um you know it's just about
bringing happiness to people around the
world
my name is John I love to work out all
day long singing this song while I'm
getting strong you know of course the
the fans here in the states love your
accent too that's what I've noticed when
I've when I've been there in the past
even with friends our accents get
stronger and become more Australian when
we get over there it's got to be a
little strange to
almost sex symbol status with also being
a wiggle I mean have you seen these
comments John I mean some of them say
I'm about to risk it all for the purple
wiggle the OG purple wiggle was a father
figure to me and now the current purple
wiggle is just a daddy or is something
like to say a zaddy I mean what do you
what do you think of it does it make you
at all uncomfortable just a crazy
concept of you know like I'm in The
Wiggles and that's the main focus you
know it's about bringing joy and
entertainment and education to young
children and it is positive it's it's
the parents of of the children and if
we're entertaining the whole family then
whatever that whatever that is
it will be whatever it will be the wild
thing too is like you know your
demographic with this show really is for
the kids but now there's a whole new
demographic
of course you mentioned your wife is so
supportive what does your wife think of
the entire internet fawning over her
husband he's she's super she's super
positive like she's a really really cool
girl she's always being like that since
day everyone we've been together for
over 10 years now so she's she's very
she she should probably be part of the
comments she'll jump on board and start
you know riding and jumping on the train
with with everyone else in the US and
around the world and yeah she's it's
just been positive now are there any
favorite memes or reactions or things
that you have seen on the internet that
you just can't shake
there are plenty there's one saying you
know the purple wiggle is going to be
the next James Bond or something like
that like I just saw one of these memes
put out there but you know whatever will
be listen I was gonna ask you know what
are the what are the career aspirations
too I mean do you think you could could
balance you know Wiggles by Day James
Bond by night or we can bring James Bond
to Wiggly world listen you're speaking
it into existence I love it yeah that'd
be cool so anything's possible in wiggle
town
monkey
a monkey monkey
[Music]